notice something strange about this tree
it's crooked it's growing straight out
and then shoots up weird seeking out the
sunlight you know I bet you all kinds of
people walk by or drive by this tree and
they don't notice that it's that crooked
but once they've noticed it they'll
always notice it so in language learning
there are three keys one is your
attitude do you like the language do you
think you can learn the language are you
confident are you positive motivated
that's number one number two are you
willing to put in the time because it
takes a lot of time typically if you're
motivated you're gonna put in the time
the third key is developing that ability
to notice but you don't have to worry
about that because as you continue
listening and reading you notice more
and more things and once you've noticed
them you notice them again and once
they've been noticed by you they're sort
of already there and you notice new
things so the ability to notice develops
naturally as long as you have the right
attitude and you put in enough time